What exactly is your
relationship with Robert Berchtold?
Well, he's practically
a member of the family.
Good morning, Brobergs.
-Good morning, Brother B.
-Good morning, B.
Good morning, Jan.
It's going to be a great day.
Hey, who do you love the most?
Brother B!
Tell you the truth a man like you, a
father, and a church leader.
I wanted to be friends with you
from the moment I met you.
Really?
I almost feel like we're two sides
of the same family.
I look at you and Mary Ann,
and sometimes I wish
I had the kind of marriage you have.
If you really care about me, Broberg.
Help me out, brother.
No one thinks that
their best friend is a monster.
But he has all the hallmarks
of a psychopathic personality.
Happy birthday, Jan.
Robert Berchtold doesn't feel
emotions the way that we do.
He will lie and manipulate
to get the only thing that he wants.
You remember what I told you?
You sure are special.
Who is her father?
Him or me?
Gail?
If you knew something
you would tell us, right?
Your husband kidnaped her again!
Where is Jan?
Where is she?
There's no telling what
he is capable of.